qu'en est-il de Prince,
c'est aussi
jaune, nous sommes très heureux de
vous avoir tous les deux ici ce soir, les garçons vierges et
Dita Amelia, alors quand vous étiez avant d'être
membre de jaune, vous étiez
chauffeur de camion est-il vrai que c'est vrai oui et
vous écrivez de la musique pendant  la nuit
et le jour, nous écoutons votre
musique dans votre morceau et vous ajoutez de nombreux
accidents non n'est-ce pas le dernier des derniers
mois j'ai fait trois accidents complets toute la
voiture a été brisée alors la société pour laquelle je
travaille dites-moi maintenant  la
surence comment s'appelle ouais l'
assurance l'assurance ne paierait plus
pour ces accents donc je savais que ton père
était un homme très riche c'est un homme très riche
c'est un banquier non un banquier très célèbre et riche
je ne sais pas s'il est riche  ou
pas il est aisé et c'est un banquier ouais
mais je ne sais pas du tout tu n'es pas
impliqué dans le rock and roll tu dis
qu'un français qui joue du rock and roll
c'est comme un japonais qui joue à la jonglerie
c'est pour dire toi tu penses  ce n'est pas notre
culture et vous n'êtes pas du tout dedans
oui je pense que vous savez qu'on nous demande en
Amérique ou en Angleterre où nous avons du
succès on nous demande toujours comment se fait-il
qu'en Suisse quelque chose
comme ça puisse arriver et je dis toujours
que nous sommes très provinciaux dans la mesure où
nous n'essayons pas de copier le rock and roll
parce que ce ne sont pas nos routes musicales
ouais et c'est pourquoi je pense par exemple
en France si je puis dire pour que beaucoup de
musique ne retourne tout simplement pas à  les
racines que la France a musicalement mais c'est comme une
culture importée et juste reprise
comme quand je mets une nouvelle veste tu sais
et c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas vraiment
profond parce que ça ne vient pas de tes
racines c'est quelque chose qui t'enfile juste
comme  un autocollant et puis vous jouez du
rock and roll vous pouvez être très parfait
en le faisant mais il n'a pas d'âme il s'agit de
vous dans votre votre nouvel album appelé drapeau
vous dites le plus jaune de notre album qu'est-
ce que cela signifie drapeau est comme une devise
pour vous  maintenant je pense que c'est une
situation très difficile pour un musicien ou
pour tous ceux qui créent quelque chose
si tout à coup je veux dire tout à coup au cours des
trois quatre dernières années, nous avons eu plus de
succès public vous avez ce succès c'est comme
si les gens vous lançaient de l'or ouais et
ça  le but peut euh vous tuer vous savez à
la manière de James Bond si vous êtes couvert d'or
vous ne respirez plus vous êtes
comme votre doigt droit et ce
drapeau du coude et le titre signifient que nous
essayons de maintenir l'identité de  le
petit drapeau de nos petites idées
en face de la situation où du coup on
doit se sentir responsable de tout l'
argent qu'on se fait parce qu'on a
réussi alors maintenant on va jouer à un petit
jeu c'est une sorte d'interview qu'on fait
assez souvent dans cette émission c'est  a appelé
l'interview habituelle
[Musique]
Brian Ferry que pensez-vous de Ryan
Ferry Bryan Ferry est un artiste très classique,
un vrai crooner, un
entrepreneur classique qui, lorsque Roxy Music a commencé,
avait inventé un tout nouveau style de musique,
nous ne devrions jamais oublier que nous étions
entourés  par le rock and roll quand il a
commencé avec Roxy Music et il est toujours en
quelque sorte le père d'un tout nouveau
mouvement d'accord double de
très bons amis à moi ont eu hier
un appel téléphonique oui avec un membre de oui
vous appréciez ce qu'ils font oui
oui je pense  ce sont de très bons
auteurs-compositeurs pour être un peu critiques ouais je
me sens critique soyons critiques euh
j'aimerais qu'ils
soient un peu plus aventureux dans leur production tu sais je
pense qu'ils sont très doués pour le classique
tu veux dire qu'ils sont un peu trop lisses  à
mon goût ok prochaine coupe là je pense que
c'est le contraire du travail d'artisanat jaune
qu'ils veulent devenir comme des machines comme des
robots ils aiment être des robots et le jaune
utilise la haute technologie ouais la nouvelle technologie
comme l'os va du 20ème siècle nous
ne '  t nous ne sommes pas impressionnés par la technologie
nous l'utilisons ouais vous savez et ils
aimeraient être techniques ils aimeraient
être des robots d'accord donc c'est le contraire d'accord
Talking Heads parce que vous êtes assez je
déteste les sports ah vous les avez mangés ouais non je je
déteste euh  La voix de David Byrne ouais c'est c'est
vraiment ça colle exactement là la
musique j'aime j'aime beaucoup très radical
euh je
pense
qu'est ce que les gens disent aussi
de nous je pense qu'il y a parfois un
peu trop Arty un peu trop étudiant en art vous
savez et  récemment, je veux dire depuis
quelques années, ils essaient de s'éloigner
de cela en utilisant euh des
rythmes très noirs, une sorte de
débarras très roulant et je pense que c'est un
très très bon développement pour eux mais
fondamentalement, je les aime surtout en
sachant  à quel point il est difficile de
créer quelque chose d'individuel en Amérique
dans ce secteur, vous savez que c'est la
chose la plus difficile au monde de
traverser les murs de l'ignorance en
Amérique, qu'en est-il de Prince
oui
alors
et vous un prince pour moi est un virtuose
il est  un conglomérat de génie de toutes sortes
d'idées différentes, c'est un brillant
arrangeur et je pense que tous ensemble,
il
change un peu trop souvent l'
image qu'il me donne comme un magicien qui avait
une boîte devant lui et il
sort cette empreinte qui  Prince ou
voulez-vous ce prince ou ce prince dont j'étais
un grand fan de Zappa Je pense qu'il
était très humoristique et il avait beaucoup d'
auto-repassage dans tout son truc le genre
d'approche funky Jazzy Rocky qu'il avait
musicalement après un certain temps  c'est devenu un peu ennuyeux
pour moi
tellement d'albums et le dernier mais pas des moindres
Jimmy et les tarifs
sympa bon guitariste
Chloé était il était juste trop court sur cette
planète
Great Character
est c'est vrai que tu vas t'installer à
Paris euh ouais ouais  essayer de trouver
un appartement ici parce que j'aime Paris et
j'aime Jimi Hendrix bleu